if you want to start a successful
clothing company then the first step you
need to take before anything else is to
understand what you're passionate about
why are you starting this business most
entrepreneurs start a business for the
wrong reason they start a business
because the thing that can make a lot of
money they start a business because I
see an opportunity if that's your
approach you're not going to have
success most businesses are really in
competitive industries but especially in
the clothing industry are you doing this
because you think it's going to be cool
or you're doing this because you have a
love for this kind of business and a
vision for how you can change the
fashion industry it's a huge difference
it's all the difference that'll be the
difference between success and failure
for you running and starting a clothing
business is no joke it's not easy it's
not quick money it's a hard business to
be successful in and the ones who do it
the ones who have a lot of success are
the ones who have a clear vision for
changes that they need to make in the
industry you have to believe that the
fashion industry right now is broken
there's something wrong with it and you
can fill that gap and you want to fill
that gap that's your life's purpose to
fill that gap whether you're making
t-shirts or ties or shoes or whatever it
is there's something missing and it's
your life's work to make that better to
make a change in the industry you have
to feel passionate about it you have to
want to make the change in the whole
industry if you don't have that kind of
excitement if you think it's just
something cool to do think it's a way to
make some quick money then it's going to
fail if you're not sure on what you're
going to do to get then get clear figure
it out if you know that you love fashion
you've been interested in your whole
life but you're not sure what your next
step is going to be really think about
the
mark that you want to have on this
business think about what's wrong with
it think about the things that you've
done for yourself that you couldn't find
anywhere else or things you've done for
other people clothes you've designed for
other people that they couldn't find
anywhere else you have to start with
something you have to start with
something powerful this is going to be
your message to the world this is your
mark that you're going to leave you're
creating the t-shirt line like nobody
else has ever seen before what is that
why are you different than everybody
else has come before you take the time
to think about it think about why you
love this business think about what's
going to make you different think about
the message that you want to send to the
world and make sure it's passionate
write it down and and if you look at it
the next day it should get you excited
if it doesn't then it's back to the
drawing board or it's looking for a
different business I want to save you
your time your energy your effort your
dollars I don't want you going in the
wrong direction too many entrepreneurs
start up that way they invest dollars in
the inventory into production into
building their business and they never
make a single sale because right at the
beginning they didn't have something
different their army to product there's
no heart there's no soul into what they
created there's no passion behind the
business and you end up in debt having
to close down a garage full of shirts
and you never become the entrepreneur
that you can be so do it right start
from the beginning start around the
passion started on the life-changing
idea and that will permeate through
everything that you do and dramatically
increase the chances of your success
believe
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up makes want to do more for you
and I love to hear what you have to
think about this video or if you have a
question for your own business every
morning it makes my day watching these
comments come in so please leave a
comment below thank you and I'll see you
soon